morning John last week I said some
really mean things about books and books
actually saw the video and left a really
nasty comment as an apology let's talk
about the best entertainment investments
you can make there are different kinds
and levels of quality of entertainments
and also different amounts of money you
could spend being entertained poorest
investments are usually live events of
course hopefully that means that the
quality of the entertainment desire
Super Bowl for example this year a very
bad game not interesting people pay
upwards of two thousand dollars to get a
ticket to the Super Bowl for less than
four hours of entertainment that's
that's more than $500 per hour of
entertainment that's about as bad as you
can get VidCon also a live event but it
goes for a long time it's two days and
like all the way around almost it's like
10 a.m. to 2 a.m. if you're spending all
that time being entertained and I hope
you are and you pay the current hundred
$50 per ticket price that it's $5 per
hour of entertainment that's pretty good
it's the same as if you pay $10 for a
two hour movie as long as you don't buy
the tremendously over bright snack foods
also as long as you not see the 3d movie
or in the special theater or it's a
special edition movie or you live in a
place where it's more than ten dollars
video games are one of the most popular
forms of entertainment these days
usually debuting about $60 and taking
about 40 hours to beat iPad at all
comics though I love them in their
beautiful little pieces of art and
sometimes they do hold on to their value
an investment takes like 20 minutes to
read and it's 3 bucks so that's bad
board games and card games are generally
a fantastic investment as long as you
play them once you suck the cost every
time you play it you're getting a better
value
well it's bring it on back to my friend
books The Fault in Our Stars is
currently on sale at Amazon for $7 this
book that took me about 20 hours to
finish I'm admittedly a slow reader so
let's shave some time off of that 46
cents per hour this now we're talking at
the same time though all of our other
entertainments are much more expensive
than this so really it's probably okay
to pay full price for that book I'm only
paying like sixty-seven cents more per
hour really to me that's the amount of
money I'm paying to the local bookstore
when I buy it there rather than on
Amazon sixty-seven cents per hour of
enjoyment that I am treating in exchange
for a place where I can go and look at
book size people who will help me find
things
and shells of opportunity course we
haven't even mentioned America's main
source of entertainment that being
television average cost of cable
television package is 128 dollars per
month that's a lot of money but since
the average American spends and I cannot
believe this is true 34 hours per week
watching television it's actually a
really good deal however no one's
pretending that the amount of time you
spend watching TV is comparable to the
amount of time you spend enjoying VidCon
hopefully 20 hours of VidCon is more
than 10 times more entertaining than 20
hours of television and yeah I think 20
hours of reading a book is probably more
enriching than 20 hours of playing Grand
Theft Auto doesn't seem like there's a
huge amount of correlation between the
amount of dollars delivered and the
amount of value delivered which is why I
guess it makes sense that a lot of the
best things in life are free wood you
can keep them for the bats and bees ah
mom
that's what I want
that's what I want John I'll see you on
Tuesday